are you ready for your product
management interview here's an example
of a common question that I see Google
is thinking about acquiring the question
and answer site quora should they
acquire it why or why not product
strategy is an important component of
product management for this type of
question make sure that you're not just
focused on getting to a final answer but
also demonstrate your thought process to
the interviewer along the way for
example you can start by thinking out
loud what do both these companies
fundamentally do are their missions
aligned what would Google gain from this
acquisition as the interviewer what are
goals and success criteria are for
example do we want to capture a new
target market gain new users or generate
a new Revenue stream there is no right
or wrong answer as long as you can
demonstrate how you got there and
justify your decisions to the
interviewer